know what an incredible start to the
season so far you guys what was it like
for you guys being able to lean into the
more mature elements of these characters
with um will sort of struggling to get
into high school and watching l struggle
and then on top of that having his best
friend maybe not
feel like his best friend anymore yeah
no i mean will's definitely in kind of
an uncomfortable situation and all he
wants is just to be back to normal with
his little friends in the basement but
i mean it's it's very cool just for me
as the actor to play in this new
environment where we were filming in new
mexico in the desert and it was just a
lot of fun to play around with just a
new setting that's because we're so used
to the hawkins setting
um but yeah will's like a very
protective brother for elf i think it's
it's so kind of rich to have you know in
this huge supernatural big sci-fi show
to have those real human um you know
human kind of stories and human issues
and i think in the relationship at least
from my my character's perspective he is
you know i think relationships challenge
you and it's it's kind of
making him question a lot about who
who you know who he is and whether which
path he should go down and you know i
think there's a lot of fear about
what he should do maybe being left and
it's like kind of trying to work those
dynamics and
he has argyle has his new friend who's
trying to help him navigate that uh i
don't know like in the best way but as
best as he can
um
but uh yeah
yeah it was really yeah it was really it
was really great to kind of get to play
those really cool truths in this wild
story
don't try to be heroes
there is no shame
in running
sick
what do you think mike it's risky as
hell what was it like for you guys
getting a chance to like you know
play these more mature elements of the
story you know we're dealing with
people's grief we're dealing with now
real like romantic relationship
struggles
yeah
um
i mean
yeah it's it isn't you know i think it's
like
just
respecting your characters and their and
their journeys and just um you know
there's a lot of
uh sort of supernatural crazy elements
going on um but i i think for all of us
it's about kind of grounding those
characters and like their their their
relationships and their actual lives and
feelings and emotions and i think
um having that sort of tether you
through everything is um a fun part of
this particular
job
natalia and joe it seems like there's
still a little bit of uh
steve and nancy
romantic energy happening there are we
gonna be seeing them
get together there's like a obvious
little flame i feel like when people you
know are together in the past there's
always little flames so it's fun to like
work together again actually because we
haven't really worked together in a long
time so that was really something i was
looking forward to because the
characters have kind of gone their
separate ways changed a little bit and
so when they come back what is that like
um
but you know i mean i don't know about
you but i don't really know how the hell
it'll end or what'll happen yeah no i
i'm pretty
pretty open-ended yeah they we don't we
don't know a lot yeah um
so
but there's definitely like you know i
think
what we see in this
season is like you know these are two
people who do
care about each other dear billy
i don't know if you can even hear this
[Music]
ever since you left everything's been
a total disaster max is really going
through it this season i mean we're
seeing her deal with the grief of her
brother but then she's also been
targeted by this demon um and then i
guess having her life saved by
kate bush
is she in the clear or does she still
have this mark on her as we go into this
next next few episodes
i mean there's really
no way of knowing i think the audience
doesn't know the characters certainly
don't know at this point but yeah max's
journey this season for like the you
know for the episodes that you've seen
so far
it really is just a lot because you know
she is she's in a lot of pain and she's
grieving
and
you know she's having all these really
dark thoughts that she doesn't want
anyone to find out
and then all of a sudden you know the
very thing she wants to hide the most is
is what this villain is feeding off of
um
so she
puts her in a very vulnerable position
um
and yeah and then she gets her life
saved by kate bush we're a team
friends
but it's gonna be up to us again
i'm new to this show and like at the
same time argyle's character is new to
their crazy ass lives you know they're
the wild that they've been through you
know like that it's just so it's just so
nuts like that was like the parallel
between me and argyle like it's just
like uh i'm experiencing
their their uh their show and their
stuff for the first time and then and
then argyle is experiencing
uh life-threatening situations that
they're like almost desensitized to
they're like used to like
anything like you can throw anything at
them they're like all right here we go
i mean for our guy that's like what are
you talking about
just what was like like for you
joining this uh joining this crew of
people this this this family who's been
together for a few seasons now
well you know most of them are lovely um
so that's kind of helpful no they're all
really nice people and um it was yeah it
was everything that you'd expect i think
it was kind of daunting a little bit
nerve-wracking but then also incredibly
exciting
but more than anything just kind of uh
it's a good thing to kind of go
somewhere somewhere strange with a bunch
of strangers
and then leave that place with kind of
uh really dear friends
a war is coming
i'm afraid your friends at hawkins are
very much
in the eye of the storm
i don't have my powers
i don't know how to say this other than
just to say it
without you
we can't win this war
our core group are now
separated um what sort of danger does
that pose to them like you know where
we've got everybody kind of on their own
individual
uh on their own individual story lines
at the beginning of the season
what is that what does that mean for
them
yeah i mean i think it's
it's definitely
a different feel at least for the first
few episodes just having the distance
between everyone
um
but weirdly i think it makes it all the
more exciting yeah and just having like
these very different locations to kind
of follow throughout the season it's
never
something we've done before so
it was um i don't know i think in the
duffers obviously like yeah they're
geniuses and the way they had a very
specific way that they wanted each
location to look and i think it
translates beautifully and this is new
challenges for the characters we always
survive uh and and work best as a team
and now we don't have that that option
yeah i feel like also something that
struck me was like wait a second we're
filming
okay we've got the storyline that takes
place here we've got a storyline that
takes place all the way over here and
just kind of how
far they have taken this thing
um while maintaining the core of the
show to me was like wow hats off can't
wait to do it can't wait to see it you
know and for us
we're only filming one of the storylines
so when we watch the episodes at least
i'll speak for myself i'm like wow i'm
just watching this as a fan i i didn't
see any of this on the day so that's
really fun i also feel like this season
there are characters who are in real
real danger that is surprising like who
haven't been in like as high-stakes
potential doom
danger before and uh that
was surprising and scary to me when i
was reading it and applicable to every
storyline it's not just that one
storyline is kind of
the main artery every single storyline
is kind of filled with
peril and
yeah danger now this season they don't
have at least for part of it anyway they
don't have their super powered friend to
back them up i mean what do we what does
that mean for
for them how are they able to cope and
navigate and head into hawkins to try to
save the day
without her
prep time dude it's like it's like
batman you know you need prep time you
gotta be a tactician you just gotta
you gotta brace for it i think it's just
nice because it's it's it's interesting
to see this kind of more realistic fight
against this supernatural
um being and it's like we're ju like
this season is for us we're fighting
with guns and and words and and things
that aren't like what i'm used to in the
upside down with the slime and the and
the spores and everything so it was just
really fun to try that new side of
things and it was just very realistic
and
crazy
we've had our our weapon our superpower
we have
our friend with superpowers that's
usually the fallback is when things
don't go right we can just have our
friend that can laugh and then slow
things up with their mind and so yeah of
course supposed to do challenges not yet
with everything she's dealing with and
us being separated it's
off the bat not looking great for us